cuando yo llegué a vivir a monterrey
venga todo todos los días ya podía salir
a jugar vivir en las montañas ya mí me
encantó eso y yo como en 16 años me
encantaba salir a jugar hasta que un día
yo ya no podía él sino sabido el
horrible color gris y no podía respirar
no sabía qué estaba pasando yo fui y le
pregunté una mamá y me explicó sobre un
problema que todo el mundo bueno también
el monterrey está enfrentando este
problema de la contaminación yo me di
cuenta que no mucha gente como yo en
este tiempo sabía que era la
contaminación y yo decidí cambiar eso
yo hay unos amigos nos fuimos a una casa
hogar donde ahí les enseñamos a sembrar
y para plantar
les enseñamos sobre el medio ambiente y
cómo se sustentables con ellos logramos
hacer un huerto y un invernadero lleno
de cajas con frutas y verduras
cuando regresamos plantamos aún más
árboles y pretendíamos hacer más cosas
durante un año y medio logramos hacer
esto con ellos y como les enseñamos a
ser sustentables todavía lo hacen
después de un tiempo yo y otros niños
que estábamos preocupados por nuestro
futuro y nuestros saludos nos juntamos
para formar el grupo yo respiro
monterrey nosotros en el tiempo de un
mes logramos contar más que 13.000
personas para una marcha contra la mala
calidad de aire que tenemos en monterrey
logramos juntar a los alcaldes del área
metropolitana y hablamos con el congreso
estatal sobre qué podíamos hacer para
cambiar las leyes
juntamos a los diputados ya los ya mucha
otra gente del gobierno para que nos
ayudara y no solo hicimos eso hemos
hecho muchas más cosas para el futuro
pero nos faltan nosotros nos hemos dado
cuenta que nadie sabe sobre este
problema que nos estamos enfrentando
porque estoy yo haciendo esto porque no
algunos de ustedes porque ustedes no se
dan cuenta en 2018 tenemos 204 días
respirando aire sucio imagínense más que
la mitad del año hay jóvenes jurando que
nunca van a tener hijos porque los van a
tener en un mundo sin futuro imagínense
tener que llevar esto todos los días
para solo puedes respirar aire limpio es
un futuro que nosotros vamos a tener y
nos de díaz contaminados
enfermedades y no vamos a poder curar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]